cardinals have split 10 games since
returning to play last saturday 10 games
they played in since last saturday kwon
young kim gave up one run it was a solo
homer to ian happ went three and two
thirds in his first ever start in major
league baseball yeah stuff was really
good that particular game but i imagine
he'll get stretched out a little further
than that today mike schilt being very
careful not to let his pitchers go too
many pitches davidson has big time power
and especially against the lefties he's
had 20 or more home runs
ground ball that's hit to short tommy
edmond up with it
makes the play in a one two three inning
for kk so tommy edmond a chance here for
the cardinals see if edmund can't make
him pay
the 1-1
and edmond hits it out to left-seeking
dropping base hit one run in here comes
wong bader scores wong will score
two to nothing cardinals on a base hit
by tommy edmond into left
three consecutive hits at a two-nothing
st louis lead
edmond didn't get all of that either
colton long right on the heels of
harrison bader the
now the bullpen of the cardinals they
start to stir one ball and two strikes
on galves
he got him a strikeout on the outside
corner so the reds will strand a man kim
is through five bottom of the fifth
inning cardinals coming to bat they lead
the reds two nothing and back to work is
wade miley
as bader lifts a high fly ball into deep
right center field it's at the wall and
it's gone
opposite field home run harrison bader
bader with his first of the year to make
it a three-nothing st louis lead and
he's two for two
yeah i still love that subdued
celebration in the cardinals dugout and
i also love the fact that vader has six
total bases in this game we talked about
his need to hit to stay in the lineup on
a daily basis well he's done that
tonight kim wanted to be an innings
eater well he's doing it tonight he sure
is matt davidson grounded out to short
what very well could be his final inning
of work right here
lined into right carlson sliding it he
makes the catch dylan carlson a fine
play in right field kim three hits
no walks three strikeouts no runs over
six innings he's in line for his first
major league win as gant takes over for
kwang young kim loved him right out of
the gate
this guy's gonna be
gonna be a good one
and a fly ball bader broke back now
comes in and makes the catch that's now
six and two thirds for gan
one hit
no runs this season he has faced 22
batters
curveball and
it's lifted high in the air carl cindo
with room in front of the track and
makes the catch three nothing midway
through seven the big sturdy guy tj
antone is and he just looks so much more
polished the pitch breaking ball a
looper into center irvine he's got it
nice play phillip irvin
phillip irvin had to come in a hurry he
had to go down into a slide and he's
able to reach out and make the catch boy
he jammed his left knee into the ground
and i mean big time that was a fantastic
play by the red center fielder three
nothing cardinals so the turn it over
here to andrew miller third pitcher used
pitching pitching pitching top of the
seventh but a lead off walk and now
galvez
and a ground ball double play four six
three thank you very much one pitch two
outs double play
exactly what miller wanted gallegos
inherits two runners he's appearing in
his fifth game one-and-oh with a zero
era no walks and six strikeouts
and the one-two pitch
giovanni gallegos swing and him as he
struck him out
big strikeout for giovanni gallegos
there it is again got him to chase and
adios
terrific for the cardinals bullpen it
set the bullpen up perfectly john gant
then miller and now gallegos for the
ninth
suarez and irvin to follow and a fly
ball
that'll carry out to o'neal and he's got
it for the out if the cardinals can hold
on hey eugenio suarez who is all for
three couple of fly outs and a ground
out like that
didn't even come down to the belt edmond
across the diamond in the out
is mark payton pinch hitting
taxi squad in activated yet another
left-handed bat this is a major league
debut
and a ground ball this should do it wong
is there and the cardinals win it they
shut out the reds three nothing and they
take game three of the
series marvelous pitching job by
kim gant
miller and gallegos especially by eagles
they set them down one two three here in
the uh
ninth inning cardinals uh
winning they set it up to take three out
of four